why not also investigate as we mentioned
the 574 riots in the summer of 2020 that
wreaked havoc on city after city while
democrats they either ignored it because
it was their base doing it or they uh
just said it was mostly peaceful lied to
us or they encouraged it like kamala
harris did here to answer that much more
house minority leader kevin mccarthy um
there has been questions as well once
they pulled jim jordan and jim banks why
didn't you replace them with other
people in retrospect should you have
no not at all because nothing would be
different think of this it's only the
majority who has subpoena power they
would never allow republicans into those
meetings when they interview the
individuals all they would be is the
american people would sit up there and
they would think this is a fair process
remember also whatever republican you
put up there nancy pelosi has to okay
and remember of this committee why it's
illegitimate she started it with benny
thompson who said there's only one
request
nancy pelosi is off limits we can't know
what nancy pelosi's texts are we can't
know what she said to the sergeant of
arms we can't know what she said to the
capitol police officer shouldn't the
very first question be why was the
capital ill-prepared that day why
wouldn't you look back to when they had
national guards when those riots were
going on in the summer at the lincoln
memorial nancy pelosi complaining
why wouldn't we know that and remember
what this committee is all about they
already wanted predeterminate so if you
allowed that to go forward people would
think this is a fair process it's it's
having the minority having a say no we
would not we don't have a say in it and
one of the biggest arguments i had with
the speaker is if we were going to do a
commission remember republicans proposed
one first that it would be by the way i
thought it was a good idea i thought we
should have one for the riots of 2020
and for this day you know but not one
that was you know
that had a predetermined outcome and
wouldn't answer fundamental questions if
their narrative is donald trump wanted
this supported this encouraged this but
he ordered troops to
prevent it from happening
that would make a big difference if they
presented that to the american people
remember what republicans did in january
i think it was january 13th we proposed
it on the floor that it was fair that
both sides could have subpoena power
that we would look not just at january 6
we'd look at what happened in america
that entire summer then we'd also look
at why the officer on a good friday got
killed by an individual coming up to
stab him we would look at all the
problems and we would not let nancy
pelosi off we'd want to know why it was
ill-prepared and make sure that never
happens again
it's it's obviously the fix was in from
day one sad because they should make
sure this never happens again in any
city in any town any place anywhere
all right thank you congressman hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else